[Music]
all right today's question comes from
cindy in virginia cindy writes as a
naive widow
i fell in love with a man that took over
my finances
over the past six years i've lost my
home my car my boat and my bank account
he's from canada and i'm his fourth
victim i've been going to therapy
speaking with domestic violence groups
but i've lost the support of family and
friends
how do i get out of this mess
well there's a couple things here number
one
the way you pose this question distances
you
from what happened and so as a naive
widow i fell in love with a man that
took over my finances
i would prefer you to reframe that and
say
i fell in love with the man who robbed
me
you've got to take ownership of this of
the situation you are in if you continue
to cast yourself
at sea with no boat no life raft no
ability to swim
you're never going to be able to wrap
your head around um
walking on dry land and and walking
towards solutions here
so i want you to take ownership you fell
in love with a guy you gave him
all of your finances and he robbed you
and you've got to grieve the fact that
you did that
you participated in this and then
somebody took something big from you
and going to therapy great going
domestic including your confidence
yeah he took every yeah he took your
ability to trust yourself he stole
everything from you right um but you did
play a role in that
and then if you have lost the support of
family and friends
then you need to be about finding new
community i'd want to know why you lost
family and friends and we
need to have that conversation something
in this email explains why that's right
my guess is you play a part in that too
um if
the people who love you and are around
you all of a sudden abandon you i always
want to well they came up and said this
guy's a freaking crook and you kept
playing crook and you lost everything
right and then they said we told you not
to do that and then you got upset
and you were mad at them because they
told you and they had to create
boundaries to protect themselves right
that's
that's a guess yeah right so i want you
to
call your family write them a letter
tell you i'm sorry
i'm heartbroken i miss you i'd love to
repair a relationship
and then you've got to be about finding
other people because if they've left
you've still got to have people in your
life
but this whole thing in my eyes dave
starts with ownership
taking ownership of where you are what
happened and your role in getting help
healthy and healing next there is um
it's not victim shaming no to
say that when i am a victim
that there's at least some part
that i played in that right okay there's
an old book called con man or saint
that was out it's about a guy that went
to jail for running a pyramid scheme
down in florida and ripping all these
people off
i read the book when i was like 18 years
old i was going around the motivational
movement at the time he had come out of
jail speaking and
i'm trying to say he was a saint i don't
really think he was honestly
but it's an ancient i mean it's 40 years
ago but the only thing i remember from
the book
was the title and i don't remember the
guy's name but he said
it's very difficult to con people
unless they are greedy hmm
because they are trying to get something
for nothing
and then you can set them up gotcha and
uh so they play a part in it when they
get conned in other words
okay and so and i liken it back to when
i lost everything
um and went bankrupt okay so what
happened was the bank got sold to
another bank
because the laws changed allowing that
and suddenly
the banker that i was working with that
i had trusted and done all of my deals
with and i had never been laid on a
payment
got fired and some guy in another city
looks down and says there's a kid 26
years old owes us millions of dollars in
tennessee we need to limit this
relationship which is banker talk
for screw him and run him out of
business
so the mino banks took dave out the irs
changed the laws and ronald reagan
changed the irs laws and screwed up the
snl business about that time
ronald reagan's fault that the snl
business went down
i'm a ronald reagan fan but he screwed
that business up
bad put basically put him out of
business what's the snl business
savings and loans alone okay yeah yeah
okay and so
uh that and the changes in the
depreciation schedules at that time
that reagan did to cause the economy to
recover in his mind
but he did it unilaterally and uh back
uh you know before and he screwed up
real estate values
in the instantaneously and so all of
these outside variables that i had no
control over
came crashing in on a 26 year old kid
and the banks called our notes
and that precipitated over two and a
half years losing everything we own
very easy and i did for a while sit
around and whined
and blamed everybody else it's ronald
reagan's fault the irs's fault
it's the uh the bankers the banker's
fault and they all three
did horrendous things that affected me
negatively
but guess what wouldn't have affected me
if i hadn't signed up for a trip
that i got to take got you that house of
cards i built was vulnerable
that business model i built borrowing up
to my eyeballs was vulnerable
and i i didn't know it i didn't
understand it but it doesn't matter you
don't get a pass on the law of gravity
just because you don't understand it
jump off a building it kicks in either
way
gotcha and so i i reached a point
that i was sitting in whining and a
friend of mine said what you just now
said
he said you know you can whine about
this the rest of your life and you'll
just be that guy
or you can take all these lemons and
make some lemonade because guess what
you signed up for a trip you got to take
you got the crap beat out of you
but you went in the ring with people and
they beat the snot out of you you didn't
have to go in the ring
got you and i went my fault yeah
so i quit saying the banks put me out of
business
i started saying i signed up for a trip
i got to take
and it changed everything in my heart it
it gives you it
it's like being in the ocean and you
suddenly find yourself out and it's too
deep
and you're kicking your legs kicking
your legs you're kicking your legs and
then there's that moment when your
feet finally touch the sand and you just
can go okay i'm here
right and if this woman if if cindy from
virginia was here
i would hug her and weep with her yes
yes this guy stole everything yeah
this guy's a scumbag well these bankers
were scumbags that i dealt with right
and and they paid for it because i beat
on them for the last 30 years on the
radio
but you got a widow here who
somebody said i love you and you're not
it was a con man oh
and she was all in and and then she gave
her checkbook to him and then she gave
her boat keys to him
and then when he misbehaved she didn't
act out on it she let it go and
something felt bad and her family told
her and her friends told her she did it
she kept going she kept going so the
person that she feels most violated here
is probably cindy yeah right that's
exactly what i was she's looking in the
mirror and going
oh i don't trust cindy because i had to
look in the mirror and i the biggest
problem i had was
this arrogant cocky young guy now
suddenly had no confidence
yeah i don't know those are uncharted
waters for most i had never been there
right i'd never been where i didn't know
all the answers
yeah right yeah oh man
but it's uh the point is that's where
healing begins
exactly exactly healing begins when you
take responsibility not for the whole
thing
and not inappropriately and saying this
guy really wasn't a con man i'm just an
idiot no that's not what we're saying at
all
but you say i'm gonna take ownership of
my part in this because
i did something that left me open to
this right
to some degree yeah my part in it that
i'm not a victim now there's part of it
you are a victim of big time
but there's part of you take your own
the only thing you can control is your
part that's it
and then once you take that that's where
healing starts it's powerful
take those lemonades baby make some
lemon we're with you take those lemons
make some lemonades i'll say it
backwards
there you go oh well this is the ramsay
show